hello I'm Doug Walker and I'm bra
blocker and this is sibling rivalry
our movie today is wreckit-ralph a film
set in a video game world kind of like
Who Framed Roger Rabbit meets Donkey
Kong and it you know I'm not going to
describe this I just do it smack the
black okay our movie today is
wreckit-ralph starring john c reilly as
a video game character sort of from the
donkey kong world who gets sick of his
job of always being the villain and
decides he's going to break loose and
try to become a hero for a change
doing this he gets wound up in other
video game worlds and kind of creates a
sort of black hole sort of scenario
where he'll not only destroy his game
but another game and there's viruses and
aliens and a whole bunch of crossover
stuff and it gets kind of confusing but
it's still good so I don't I I think I
need more night reference we thought it
was obvious
no I'll say this um both the strengths
and I guess you could say the weakness
of the film are sort of the same thing
in that they're really advertising like
there's a lot of videogame characters uh
and there's really not or they're not in
there for very long uh but I think
that's replaces a strength because then
you just have to rely on the individual
characters and they're very likable I
think I think that would have made the
movie but I was waiting for Sonic to
talk about bad touch when we talk about
going wheels are great to touch your
chewy do what we's talking about like
you know video game characters going to
other games and if you leave you die as
div' I just wanted to say just get out
of there and I learned an adult if that
bad see that's the one thing
I did you think in this movie though at
the very end in the climax like oh I
thought maybe all the videogame
characters were gonna come in and
they're gonna have this big battle or
something like that that would require
all of these corporations to get along
the hamster a 60-second I mean that's
what I'm I probably cost a fortune all
right I will say this I think looking I
think we could look back now and see
what a freaking miracle Roger Rabbit
really was but I think that also the
advantage of was there was there any MGM
characters and that was that every
morning not know that that they had
droopy and a couple of characters that
may have been the issue you had three
major corporations when you get into the
video game world
now you're talking Konami you're talking
intend oh you're talking Sega you're to
present a video game kid you've got at
Ari yeah it's it's crazy Midway Namco
like it whoever owns pong obvious
obviously I think what happened is
somebody used chloroform sorry this is
for candy I was like I mean we need to
make this really fast before any of them
wakes up and realizes what they've done
but it
I mean what's what is cool about it is
despite the fact you know that we didn't
get much of it you do get some of it and
let's be honest folks this is as close
to a Nintendo movie you're going to get
a good video game movie for not only a
good video game movie but a Nintendo
movie because like since Super Mario
Brothers they've had Pokemon and that's
it this is it this is all you get hey
Tron Legacy yeah which is kind of sort
of based on video game kind of sort of
no but I mean intend Nintendo guards
their movie licenses like it's the
friggin Holy Grail or the Ark of the
Covenant like they let one loose people
who start melting like wax but let's uh
let's hope this will actually lead to
more video game movies like ones that
they put just as much effort as they did
where they care yeah I mean just as much
ever since me I was like you just proved
you could actually make a good video
game movie oh and guess what it's about
video games I think it's not like oh
we're gonna take Super Mario Brothers
and it's gonna be about Dennis Hopper
I'll put him in the city yeah
like you actually did this and it's
about video games why do people do this
well what I like is that they're mixing
the satire of current games you know and
old games while also using some of the
characters but they all set to remake
some of their own worlds like you know
the shirt and Rogers sort of Mario
Carrie yeah we're complaining about it
but let's be honest for what they had to
do because it's pretty impressive yeah
it's obvious they couldn't get all of
these things it's too much copyright
going on
they created a Mario Kart game but I
looked at it was like I want to play
that nice instead I wish we totally play
that sure it looks like Rainbow Brite
farted all over Mario Kart instantly but
we chose wait the voice actors I mean
they just fit like a glove I mean they
totally slipped into the UH john c
reilly well he's like guessing calls
answer for we need every man every bill
passed it's getting too old John see uh
Sarah Silverman weather hasn't around
for a while I think she just does great
she was like kind of like hitting this I
did like her show but her humor is just
very like there sometimes I'm like she's
hilarious other times like I thought she
yeah she's kind of like Dane Cook like
that like it just depends on my mood but
like yeah she was perfectly cast in this
and Jane Lynch who is contractually
obligated to be in everything it's loose
some reason still managed not to like
annoy me by being in this has one of the
funniest back stories of any cameras
best the visual it don't don't get
you'll for this don't give it away but
they think it's a lot of magicians like
the sergeant's and they give her this
like horrific backstory that like I
couldn't stop laughing so tragic and
funny at the same time and that's and
that's the thing I think the kids like
there's sort of an element of the kids
at least when I saw it like that night
then they were just like oh my god
that's awful about what for laughing
that's great so but no it's the one
interesting thing is it reminded me of
men in black 3 which people like if they
asked me it's like weird you think of
MIB 3 and I'm like not that funny but
probably the most character-driven men
in black movie ever made I mean at least
since the first yeah I would say there's
not a little shorter on the last yeah
yeah it's not me well it's not Shrek but
it's so creative too in the way that
create this videogame where I think
everybody's had this idea it's a way
they go from world to world it's
completely driven by story characters
with interesting backstories an
interesting moral lesson yeah you want
to talk about the moral lesson for a
second
maybe you should just accept the fact
that you suck I'm like wow Disney that's
awesome that's the first time I'm like
it's not just to make care to do the
other characters have to go through a
lesson to see that's why I like oh yeah
no it's a but I like that it's about
live and let live and acceptance but
like what I really think it was like wow
so at the end you go through this entire
adventure using you know what my life
kind of blows and I'll always be kind of
looked at this way but you know I guess
I have a purpose and that purpose is to
suck so once I come to grips with that
you know but he also helps our people
find their purpose and stuff like that
to like you know like hey I like it more
yeah I'm like no I your dreams will come
true you'll find your friends like that
you blob that's okay that's okay I'm bad
and that's alright so uh bottom line I
think we both really really like this
might see it don't expect to laugh every
second yeah it's not a dire comedy but
it's real strong characters creative
story
um and the plethora can't be guessing to
which I like you may see the twist
coming at the end but I actually it sort
caught me off-guard and I I really
enjoyed the twist um it's funny because
it's another interesting thing where
it's like it's lame and yet the payoff
and the joke made it so worth it I find
you know what I'm Dharma it's like well
this place just got interesting and it
was worth it just for that one line and
it's like everywhere every time you
think it's gonna go interact you're not
gonna like it brings it to a better
director you never thought of and I
really like it for that no it was it was
creative and it was good and like I I'll
take a sequel yeah
judging by the video game rules is gonna
be completely different they have
nothing to do with the rest of the
series and then people are gonna
consider it the black sheep and then
next thing you know they'll be a third
game which will be better
nah I'll watch it either way wreck-it
Ralph to a look like Zelda - okay
regularly that's yeah he'll be pulling
up vegetables that's what we need to all
be out vegetables
Dracula's car
you know too many bread girls good night
injects like an outwards a side-scroller
now even though Richie was a top-down
RPG good yeah I think take all the words
to video game sequel elements we best
not write this equal because we probably
do all that actually if you like girls
minions okay so uh guys thank you so
much this was sibling rivalry uh if
there's any nostalgic movies because
that something else we're gonna do we're
gonna be looking at nostalgic movies
preferably good ones ah but not Garbage
Pail Kids it's just a film that you
enjoyed seeing growing up and maybe you
want us to look at or talking about even
if a man and Robin let us know on second
thought just don't send us it just
kidding but let us know what nostalgic
movies you like us to look at talk about
maybe something you thought deserves
more attention and we'll see if we can
take a look at please make it night trap
we need to look at night trap just the
video parts actually let's play it let's
go boobies